[Music]
here's your money briefing for Wednesday
March 29th I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
when a company announces plans for
layoffs everyone dreads the list but how
do companies decide which employees to
cut wsj workplace reporter chip cutter
joins me with more hey chip thanks so
much for being here thanks for having me
so Chip it sounds like this isn't an
enjoyable process for anyone but what
are some of the basic factors that go
into instituting a series of layoffs
well at many companies it's the top
leaders the CEO of the Chief Financial
Officer who set a high level criteria
for a layoff mandating that a company
cut a certain percentage of its
Workforce or reach a specified cost
savings and from there the task of
deciding who should be eliminated often
Falls to divisional leaders and
department heads according to many of
the executives that we spoke with all
right so take us through the typical
process here starting with a company who
is recognizing the financial need to cut
back workers and then up until the
actual layoffs so department leaders are
told to come up with the proposed list
of individuals to lay off based on a set
criteria so that could include anyone
who got a low rating and recent
performance review or who joined the
company in the past six months managers
will then compile this list of employees
to let go and oftentimes it's
interesting companies will give these
layoff documents code names like project
Falcon so the file's purpose is unclear
if it is accidentally discovered in
addition to reviewing an employee's
performance history many companies also
consider workers potential to adapt and
take on new jobs in the future one CEO
told me it's really down to a one-on-one
assessment of performance in determining
who you're going to keep now you
mentioned that it could be employees
that have been with a company for only
about six months that could wind up on
the layoff list so how much does
seniority or length of service at a
company factor into this well today's
much more common for companies to
conduct layoffs based on skills rather
than tenure so an employee's recent
performance will factor into this a lot
more than someone's length of time at a
company employees with high salaries
also might face greater attention though
corporate advisors say those workers
might also be among a company's top
performers so maybe it doesn't make
sense to cut them you know chip you
haven't mentioned Human Resources yet
doesn't that department have a say in
who stays and who goes many think it is
the job of HR to select the individual
employees to terminate though it's often
far more likely that the Business
Leaders in each area of a company that
suggests names of employees to Target so
it's not HR doing this work it's
oftentimes the divisional heads the
department heads selecting the
individual names and once individual
employees are identified HR then gets to
work in scrubbing the list looking to
see if a company is for example
disproportionately laying off people
over the age of 40 or unfairly targeting
minorities or veterans or other groups
any kind of discrimination like this
could open an employer to a lawsuit and
so companies also sometimes rely on
outside help in this too they might buy
tools or software or engage lawyers to
sift through a layoff list to look for
any possible red flags all right so when
the list is being finalized for the
layoffs is that done deal or is there
ever room for a negotiation well debates
are frequent everyone I talked to for
this said there's oftentimes a lot of
back and forth a lot of revision some
managers might attempt to jockey for
certain employees to remain and disputes
can emerge between leaders about the
philosophy of a layoff say whether to
cut a layer of middle management or to
fire more Executives over Frontline
employees and even when companies decide
to shut down entire business units
Executives might make the decision to
keep some high achieving employees and
move them elsewhere so lots of room for
debate now you spoke to Executives at
the business software company OCTA about
recent layoffs that were carried out
there how do they decide who to cut this
was an interesting example in February
OCTA said it would cut 300 employees or
five percent of its staff after the
company said like others that it over
hired in the pandemic and so many
departments across the company were
given specific Financial cost cutting
targets to meet and they did so in
different ways so some of the Innovation
and product development teams gave
priority to keeping people who are
working on projects and goals that seem
achievable in a three-year timeline
versus a five-year one and OCTA
elsewhere in the company eliminated some
sales people who are focused on small
and medium-sized businesses in North
America so you could just see the
different choices that the company made
here sounds like the common theme Here
is that sales is a good place to be it
can be those who bring in Revenue can
maybe be a little more safe if they're
seen as core to the company but it
depends on what the company does it
depends on what a company decides it
needs to focus on over the next couple
years all right that's Wall Street
Journal workplace reporter chip cutter
chip thanks for being with us on the
show always a pleasure thanks for having
me and that's your money briefing I'm
J.R Whalen for the Wall Street Journal
[Music]
thank you